Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome to the rest is history and um this is an episode that i have been looking forward to a long time um dominic ever since we we began doing this series there's been certain episodes that uh we've kind of mapped out um and this for me is definitely one of them because my wife sadie is a midwife um and so you have talked of nothing else i think it's fair to say i have very very much wanted to do uh an episode on the history of childbirth the history of midwifery because of course being married to a midwife it makes you very very interested in the subject but also
you've been sending me endless messages saying i will get so much credit at home when we do this childbirth episode i can't wait i don't know what you what benefits or rewards you think are going to be flowing your way tom well i i think that the joy of seeing my beloved wife listen to um an absolutely splendid episode listen to yourself listen to you no because we have we have a wonderful guest to talk about. We do. Do we not? Who do we have? So obviously it's two men. We're not really equipped to talk about the history of childbirth.
I mean, admittedly, a lack of knowledge and experience has never happened to us in the past. But we thought that this time we'd have a proper expert. So we have Sarah Reid, who is, I'm very happy to say, who is a literary historian, senior lecturer from Loughborough University. And not only has she written loads about women's experiences and women's bodies in the early modern period, she's also the author of a historical novel called The Gossip's Choice, which I think she's going to tell us the interesting link with midwifery in a second. And she's got a book called The Midwife's Truth out in September. And that's what we're after, Tom, isn't it?
The Midwife's Truth out in September. And that's what we're after, Tom, isn't it? The Midwife's Truth. It is. So I'm hoping you're going to tell us all about the midwife's truths, as it were, today. So welcome to the show. Thank you. That was nicely done. Yes, The Gossip's Choice is about a midwife practicing in 1665 against the backdrop of the Great Plague.
And it's called The Gossip's Choice because gossips were the women who attended other women in childbirth. So my midwife is the best midwife in the area. She's the Gossip's Choice. She's the one you want. So a gossip, hold on, is that where the word gossip comes from? Yes. So gossip derives from the same root as godparent and is God's helper, if you like, it's God's representative. And so the women who accompanied other women through their labour and supported her, propped her up quite literally, you know, sat behind her and gave her strength, were known as gossips. And then, of course, you've got people worrying about what's going on in these all-female environments and the conversations that may or may not be going on. And so you get the sort of broad use of gossip as we know it today.
Oh, Tom, I bet you didn't know that did you know that i didn't know that um but it's so i mean it's a kind of interesting point that for men in a sense childbirth is the the sphere perhaps where men are most likely to feel excluded and that therefore men have written the histories. And so, to an extent, in looking at the kind of the broad sweep of how men have written about childbirth, have you picked up a kind of sense of suspicion, of hesitation, of doubt, of uncertainty of the kind that would explain how it is that gossip comes to have the kind of pejorative term that it does today? Well, men have written about childbirth with confidence over the years. So even in the 17th century, you've got midwives pushing back on men writing about childbirth.
So famously, Nicholas Culpepper, the hypocrisy that we've all heard of from the Civil War era, wrote and translated a number of midwifery textbooks, but was widely believed never to have been in a birthing chamber himself. But that didn't stop him writing with authority on the topic. Interestingly, after his death, his wife then registers as a midwife. So there was a family interest in it, but he personally hadn't got any experience, but that didn't stop him writing. And so nearly all the contemporary texts that I work on are written by men. So if you go all the way back, and I'm going to do Melfin Bragg, go back to ancient Greece.
Was that your Melfin Bragg, Tom? Yes, back to ancient Greece. All this time, and it's a terrible impersonation. I thought it was quite a good one. Well, what do you think, Sarah? I'm going to be discreet, yeah. That tells the same story. Brilliant.
So am I right, Sarah, that the first named midwife is an Athenian called Agnodike? Who may not have existed at all. It's largely now thought by classicists that it's a myth rather than a real historical figure. And one grew up from the idea of women being excluded from the academy and not being able to have the formal training in medicine that men could receive at that time but sort of she disguises herself doesn't she as a man um so when is this is this in sort of classical the age of century bc okay so century after pericles so yeah this story grows up that um this this woman wants to attend women and the only way she can do that or she can send women in but to get the advanced knowledge she needs to be um in the company of physicians um and she can't get access
without disguising herself as a man um the story falls down on um on the idea that there was no formal registration process for men at that time either so you know it's all a little bit woolly about where where it came from and what was going on with that story but it's certainly um a myth that's that's been passed down through the ages but because because what's what strikes me about that is that i had always assumed that women were the midwives that that this was this was pretty much a given but is that not the case in say I don't know, in the ancient world in Greece or whatever? Is it men who have a responsibility for attending women in labour? It's always been the case that women have attended other women. So again, it adds another layer to the confusion of
the story, where men and physicians were called in is if there were complications, if things were going wrong, if they needed some sort of you know advanced care and that carried on right throughout time so it may well be that um to get the rudimentary sort of everyday caring skills that a midwife needed at the time that was that was fine and that was done sort of with knowledge transfer between women but um this character who probably wasn't real wanted to get more knowledge, more theoretical knowledge. And to get that, she would need to pass herself off as a man. I see. So I'll tell you who is absolutely a brilliant expert on midwifery and has some absolutely splendid advice.
Dominic, can you guess who it is? He's a top Roman mansplainer. The Emperor Caligula? No, it's Pliny the Elder. OK, that doesn't surprise me. So here is some top midwifery advice some uh from plinny um it is said that it is said that a difficult labor comes immediately to term if over the house where the woman giving birth is lying someone throws a stone or a missile that has killed with a single stroke three living creatures a human being a boar and a bear and he goes on to specify that the best um missile is a light cavalry spear sarah how plausible i mean that's laughable isn't it i mean did people were
people out spearing boars and bears on the off chance that in a few years they'd need this missile to guarantee them an air or something? It seems very unlikely to me. But it's a very specific item to find as well, isn't it? It's got to have killed three different kinds of creatures. And you've simply got to get hold of one. I mean, that phrase pops up in quite a lot of the texts that I read, simply get hold of this, that or the other. And you think, well, that doesn't sound remotely simple, actually. Where is that kind of stuff coming from? Because presumably the kind of the border zone between midwifery care and magic, there's always been
a sense of blurring there, do you think? I think there is in every situation where there are unknowns and things seem quite miraculous. I mean, the birthing process is one of those, isn't it, where it just seen quite miraculous and therefore it leaves itself open to these to the magic uh line blurring but the idea that objects inanimate objects took on qualities was broadly held so the the the stone then takes on certain qualities from the experiences it's had let me ask a a question that we got from Karis, I think it is, on our Discord channel for the Restless History Club members. So Karis says, what do we know about the average age
of first-time mothers over the centuries? And what is the optimal age for giving birth? So in other words, when we're talking about childbirth and midwifery and so on, in periods before our own, we're generally talking about people who are giving birth much younger than the average British woman woman does today aren't we well not in the early modern period no popular understandings of this are skewed by the fact that aristocracy and people of higher ranks got married much younger than the average Joe in the street did
so the average age for marriage in the early modern period so we're talking about the 17th century mainly was which was about 24 for a woman 26 for a man all right so so much later than you would but does that does marriage map on does the age of marriage and maybe this is a too too banal a question does that map onto the age of childbirth in other words some people presumably would be giving birth before marriage obviously um so do we know what the average age was where people had their first child um not not really but we do know that up to a third of women were pregnant when they got married in the 17th century yeah yeah in 16th 16th 17th century it's been estimated from looking at marriage lines and birth records in church records you can see i mean people like famously william shakespeare and hathaway um she was expecting their eldest when they uh when they got wed so that's that's quite normal and the reason
that it is quite normal is because of the betrothal um arrangements whereas when a couple get engaged now it's sort of just you know an understanding between them whereas betrothal was a bit more than that in the past it was um a firm promise a commitment and once that had been shared between the couple and their families and the wider community then um often people would begin sleeping together because you know they were married in all but name at that point you're responsible for childbirth in the 17th century are you drawing on folk wisdom when you you attend a labor or are you drawing on the kind of legacy that Pliny gives you and you're chucking stones over houses and things? Or are there other traditions that you're
drawing on? To what extent is it formalised? Where are these traditions coming from? The first English language midwifery guide appears in 1540. And it's a translation of a much translated text that originally comes from German and appears in 1540. And it's a translation of a much translated text that originally comes from German and appears in nearly every continental language. And it's at some point translated into Latin. And it's from the Latin that we get the English translation. And so from 1540, that text in various forms stays in print for well over 70 years. You're still seeing versions of it in the 1620s. What's it called? called the birth of mankind the birth very good the birth of mankind or the woman's book is its subtitle um and so that that appears all across europe and there's a whole um flurry of midwifery texts
from this time onwards in the english language and they draw their learning, their theoretical knowledge, from the ancients, so from Galen and from the Hippocratic texts. Nearly all the theoretical knowledge in these books is quite similar. And it's all drawing on that body of knowledge that's been handed down from the ancients. So that's where medicine is coming from. Midwifery is coming slightly differently. It's coming from training that's hands-on you know so mothers training their daughters um and and that sort of thing so when you get the first midwifery guide that's written with a woman's name jane sharp
in 1671 she's drawing on a lot of the ideas that are present in certain of the texts, so certainly ones that were translated by Nicholas Culpepper and people like that who is taking works from a body of authors. But also she's reading widely. She's picking the best bits that she thinks are the most applicable. But what she says is that to be a good midwife, you need to have speculative knowledge, so you need to have theoretical knowledge, and you need to have theoretical knowledge and you need to have practical knowledge. You need to have the hands-on experience.
And she said the very best midwives have got a combination of both. So that's why she's coming into print in 1671 with that idea. So talk us through, you become pregnant at the end of the 16th century or the beginning of the early modern period, let's say, and you're of the middling sort. What happens? So do you withdraw to your... I mean, I have the haziest,
most probably utterly inaccurate view of what happens. So I have this sort of sense that you withdraw at some point and are not seen for weeks before your due date or whatever. And then there's people sequestered in the room with you and your husband is waiting outside but is that completely wrong i mean what how does it work yeah that that doesn't apply to sort of middling sorts or um everyday people some of that may have come from accounts of royalty um and aristocracy that tells you the way my mind works who've got access to the funds to live from you know that sort of a life but for
most women it would be a question of carrying on working in the family business as you know most families ran cottage industries from home most trade was done like that wasn't it so everybody participated in the family occupation whatever that might be and there wasn't the finances or the wherewithal generally for women to retire and stop working. And so what you would find was that women would carry on pretty much as normal until their labour pain started. And then what happens? Then what happens is that you call the midwife. And normally your husband is the one who sent off. So you see in men's diaries from the era, People like Ralph Jocelyn will write how they were sent off to find the midwife because the
woman had gone into labour. And at that point, certain ritualistic processes can kick in. So the midwife, we might think that the first thing the midwife does is to do a medical assessment and things like that. But in the 17th century, your midwife is much more likely to gather everybody to say a prayer because the link between religion and midwifery is very strong. And so there would be a sort of communal prayer for happy delivery, for a happy outcome. And from then on, the midwife was in charge. This was her domain. And around the woman who was labouring would be a group of friends neighbors the gossips that we started out our conversation talking about they might be her mother they might be her mother in law they might not all be her choosing it might not not be um you know might be politic
to have certain people there surely the last person you want is your mother-in-law but it would be a public affair would it i mean it would be a community affair a community affair yes definitely and that was important because part of what you're doing is you're introducing the infant into your community acknowledging them in a very public way and so the father sending for the midwife is all part of that process of making this baby be born into its community rather than just now in this sort of nuclear family that we often live in. That's very alien to people in the 17th century. So yeah, so it would be a very
community-led process. So you would have neighbours, as I say, some family, and the midwife was in charge. You talked about the role of religion. Just two questions on that. One from Amy VC. How has the Christian idea that childbirth ought to be painful, as described in Genesis, so that's the curse put on Eve by God, influenced medical developments and obstetrics? But just before that, this is a question from Sadie, my wife, who has an incredible collection of medieval paintings of the Virgin giving birth to Jesus, in which there are midwives. And she asked, she wanted, is there anything useful that can be learned about the history of childbirth from all the medieval paintings that show midwives attending the Virgin's labour? So I guess the idea that childbirth should be painful, which you get in Genesis,
and the idea that the Virgin giving birth to Jesus then kind of washes away that sin, it makes childbirth very, very important in the way that Christians understand the world. It absolutely does. So thinking about the medieval paintings that have got lots of midwives and the virgin, midwives are all associated with religion and with it being part of a religious duty, going back to the sort of early Christianity. And Jane Sharp, who I mentioned a few moments ago, opened her book by claiming the role of midwife as set out in, giving an example from Exodus. And she says that, and let me read a little bit of here. She says, you know, it's extremely requisite that a midwife be both fearing God, faithful, and exceedingly well experienced in
that profession. Her fidelity shall not only have reward here from man, but God has given special example in Exodus 1 in the midwives of Israel, who were so faithful to their trust that the command of a king could not make them depart from it. And she goes on to say that, you know, because of their behavior in Exodus, God gave them this special status.
Oh, that's brilliant. I would say you'd be delighted to know that. And just on the question of midwives, because you said, you know, you had this sort of image that I think we're probably all kind of familiar with of the sort of the husband rushing to get the midwife. Who are the midwives? So at what point do you decide to become a midwife? Is it random? But what I mean is, is there somebody in a given village who is absolutely the midwife and everybody turns to that person? Or could the midwife be a more informal kind of role?
Yes, both. So in every parish, generally, there would be a former midwife. And that's somebody who's got a license to practice as a midwife. A license? A license. And who is issuing the license? Well, the licensing came in in the early 16th century so it's a tudor thing and it's an ecclesiastical license to practice so the bishop
decides if you're going to be a good midwife or not how does the bishop know i mean he's a bishop yeah he knows because to get a license it's a complicated and expensive uh fairly um arduous ordeal to get a midwifithery license. So you need to have testimonials. You need to have about six women who can vouch for you. And normally it'd be their husbands writing a letter of recommendation or signing their name, even if it was with an X, to say that you had attended their birth and that you behave properly as you would expect, and everything was fine. So you need testimonials. And then you need to take an oath, the midwife's oath. There's various versions of this throughout the two
centuries that it applied, because it sort of dies out in the 1730s. It never comes to a formal end, but it just stops happening. And these oaths include things like promising that you will treat rich and poor alike, that you won't go off mid-attendance of a poorer woman to go and attend to a rich woman where you'll get a much greater fee. Promising that you'll be a good, godly woman, and that's part of what the church is looking for. And you have to also promise things like that if the child dies in the delivery, that you will make sure they're decently buried. And that involves finding a decent place, not in consecrated ground because the child wouldn't be baptized, but somewhere they couldn't be dug up accidentally by a dog or a pig, for example. So treating the child's body with respect. And that would be your responsibility. So this midwife is quite involved, you know, and some of them have got up to 15 clauses that you're agreeing to.
But this is all done by the church. So it's a church that keeps the register. And every visitation, when the bishop goes on his tours and visits parishes, the licences come up for renewal. Not in a formal sense that you present something, you're given something. But, you know, is Mrs. So-and-so still doing well? And can I see her and talk to her and this sort of thing. So the church was very much involved for a 200 year period. And again, it comes back to the importance of midwifery as a religious duty. So you have licensed midwives, they may be depending on the size of the area, you know, there may be more than one of those, but they're trained by a sort of apprenticeship system. So up to six years,
sometimes as little as three. In 1737, Sarah Stone, who's a midwife from Bristol, originally from Somerset, she writes that three years is enough. Other people thought six. And midwives often called their apprentices their deputy. And they traveled around together. And eventually, the deputy would gain enough experience to do a delivery. And once they'd got a certain number, then they could start thinking about applying to be a midwife in their own right. But at the other end of the scale and where there wasn't a licensed midwife, there would be hand women, sort of the same derivative as farmhand. And they would just be the local woman who'd got lots of experience in childbirth. She probably had a number of children herself. She was was the one that people called to but she'd never
gone down the formal licensing route and that sort of raises a question from simon g another of our club members he says um to what extent were midwives marginalized as witches by a predominantly male clerical and medical establishment as medicine began to be codified in the early modern period so were were some midwives sometimes seen as witches no sarah no no that's a myth yeah in right back in the late 80s um david harley writes at length about this and finds no evidence for midwives being treated as witches so that's a sort of urban that's an urban myth yeah because i i mean anyone who has seen call thewife, an incredibly successful drama set against the backdrop of the East End in the 50s and 60s, will know how central the fact that it is under the aegis of nuns is. I mean, the religion is really important there.
And I hadn't realized quite how kind of interwoven it was even back in the in the 16th and 17th centuries but i guess kind of obvious that it was could we take a break now and and perhaps sarah we could at the end of the second half look at call the midwife but we should there are a couple of um questions on say cesarean sections and on swaddling which would be wonderful to come to after the break and then look at how the midwifery evolved the course of the 17th, 18th century into the modern period. So we will be back after the break. Thanks very much. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking childbirth, midwifery, all that kind of stuff. And there's an excellent question here from Dr. Crom, who is a classicist. And he says, I trust there'll be a cesarean section. Very good.
Very good, James. That's the sort of wit we expect from Alison. So we've had a lot of questions about this. Huel, is it true Julius Caesar was the first baby born by Caesarian section? David N., could you pass the history of the Caesarian section and the use in various cultures? Also, is there any truth to the idea this is how Caesar himself was born? And so on. So Julius Caesar, Caesarian sections, what's going on there? Yeah, it's a funny one, this, because you see repeatedly the idea that it was Julius Caesar. Well, if it was Julius Caesar, it wasn't the person that we're thinking of.
It was one of his ancestors. Because his mother lives, doesn't she? Exactly. And that's where the rather closes the case. But you do see in every culture, as far as I can say, there is examples of great people supposedly being born through surgical interventions, so through caesarean sections. So it's something that comes into most cultures, this idea that a person born to greatness would have been born in this exceptional way.
So there's no... Not duff. Not from a woman, that's right, not from a woman born. Absolutely, yeah. So, yes, it's very pervasive, but very unlikely. Up until the, really up until the 19th century, the late 19th century at that, what we think of as a modern cesarean didn't have any precedence,
you know, with the invention of sort of anesthesia and antisepsis that people could have cesarean sections and still thrive. You will see stories throughout history of people who, you know, supposedly had them and went on to have more children and survive. But how, you know, how true these are, we just don't know but it's not until as i say we get into um the late 19th century we've got what we called you know documentary evidence for it happening babies were born by surgical means but as tom alluded to it was when
the mother we'd given up hopes for the mother so it was a way of saving the child and it was very successful for that so if the mother was going to die anyway then let's try and save the child by surgical means so that that happened yeah so let's talk about mortality because we had loads of questions about that so for example dave walters has asked did mortality rates improve over time or did they actually get worse and just following up so that's one question and then the follow-up question is is from tim basby bernie and he asks given that there were obviously high risks of death compared with the figures now did men and women prepare themselves for death i.e did husband and wife kind of say almost a tearful farewell and the expectation that things might
go horribly wrong so so yeah what's the story with mortality yeah so i'll do the second part um first they they did prepare themselves and um there's a beautiful poem by the american poet anne bradstreet who published her poems published in the 1650s and she's got um a poem called before the birth of one of my children and it's written to her husband and i regularly reread it I teach it every year and I can't get through it without um tearing up it is just so touching she talks about how if if she is to die that she hopes her husband will look after their existing children she knows he'll remarry um because that's what you do but she says you know if you ever loved me then look after these children and don't let them come to any harm from this new stepdame.
But she lived. Please tell me she lived. She lived. Oh, my God. I thought Tom was going to dissolve then. Yeah. So I can't recommend that more highly, really. So people did prepare themselves. There were whole publications. The Mother's Legacy is a genre of publication in the early modern period in which mothers would write instructions for their children so that if anything happened to them there's even one from the early 17th century where the mother suggests names for her grandchildren
this is what i want to happen um but you often get you know instructions for good behavior and and things like that in these mother's legacies more generally there were prayers that were written especially for laboring women in the early stages or that she could offer up throughout her pregnancy to prepare her soul for the worst. So absolutely, it was something that was very much on people's minds. Having said that, the statistics are very much lower than we think. And they do get worse, as your questioner suspected. So in the late 17th century, the figure is 1.7% for maternal mortality in some studies that have been based on church records. We're talking about one to two per hundred, which sounds lower than we tend to think, but still means if we think about our wider network that we're going to know somebody
这就是我希望发生的事情，嗯，不过你经常能在这些母亲遗言中看到关于良好行为的指导之类的东西。更普遍的是，有些祷告是专门为早期临产的妇女写的，或者她可以在整个怀孕期间进行祈祷，为最坏的情况做好灵魂准备。所以绝对地，这是人们非常关心的一件事。话虽如此，统计数据比我们想象的要低得多。而且正如你的提问者所猜想的那样，情况确实变得更糟了。因此，在17世纪后期，根据一些基于教堂记录的研究，产妇死亡率为1.7%。我们讨论的是每百人中有一到两个人，这听起来比我们想象的要低，但仍然意味着如果我们想到我们更广泛的人脉网络，我们就会认识某个人
or know of somebody aren't we even if it's second hand or third hand removed um but childbirth generally um was very safe and you know we're talking we're talking over 98 out of 100 having a happy outcome for the mother and then and then you said it gets worse though that's the interesting thing so why would it get worse well the figure that I've got is that in 1933, it's 5.94. So why is that, do you think? Well, it's to do with, I want to say men getting involved. I don't mean very. Just say it.
或者认识某人，不是吗？即使是第二手或第三手关系。嗯，但总的来说分娩非常安全，你知道，我们谈论的是超过98%的人对母亲来说都有一个幸福的结局，然后然后你说情况变得更糟糕了，不过这很有趣，那为什么情况会变糟呢？嗯，我得到的数据是，在1933年，这个数字是5.94。你认为这是为什么呢？嗯，这与我想说的是男人们开始介入有关。我不是指非常。就直说吧。
It's fine. It's to do with the medicalization and the way that physicians were routinely involved in childbirth. And they're going from, the classic example is they've gone from post-mortem or from chopping somebody's leg off, wipe their hands down on their apron and go to the birth. And they're introducing germs into the birthing chamber, which wouldn't otherwise have been there. So the rates of pupper or fever, childbed fever, go through the roof. Oh, so that's interesting. So it's not because the men are recommending techniques that are too invasive or too intrusive or or sort of aggressive it's because they have been operating on other people
没关系。这与医疗化以及内科医生常规介入分娩的方式有关。他们从——典型的例子是，他们从尸检或砍掉某人的腿开始，在围裙上擦擦手就去接生了。他们把原本不会存在的病菌带入了产房。因此，产褥热的发生率急剧飙升。哦，这很有趣。所以这不是因为男人们推荐了过于激进、过于深入或某种攻击性的技术，而是因为他们一直在对其他人进行手术
and they they're basically bringing in you know the infection that's that's the the major thing yeah that is that just seemed to be the major thing. But also that they would be the ones who came into a difficult birth. So if surgical intervention in the form of forceps or something was needed, then it would be a man who would do that. So, yeah, so there is higher cases for things going. So that process by which childbirth comes to be medicalised is obviously really interesting. But just before we come to that,
并且他们基本上带入了——你知道——感染，这才是主要原因。是的，这似乎就是主要原因。但也是因为他们会是那些面对困难分娩的人。因此，如果需要使用产钳等形式的手术干预，那么就会由男性来完成。所以，是的，所以出现问题的病例更多了。因此，分娩被医疗化的过程显然非常有趣。但在我们讨论到这一点之前，
could I just ask one other question from Nikki Rathbone? And she's asking about swaddling. Why was it so universal from the Middle East to Native Americans for thousands of years? And why is it no longer practised? Is it still practised? It is still practised, yeah. I mean, I remember one of mine not settling in the hospital and the midwife came in and wrapped them up very, very tightly in their blanket and handed me back a pacified infant. And I thought something miraculous had just taken place. But swaddling is incredibly effective for soothing infants. So it's as simple as that. It works is basically the answer. It works. And that's the simple answer answer but it also had theory behind it um so midwives
我能问尼基·拉思伯恩（Nikki Rathbone）提出的另一个问题吗？她问的是关于襁褓的问题。为什么从苏格兰到美洲原住民，几千年来它都是如此普遍？为什么它不再流行了？它现在还在实践吗？它现在还在实践，是的。我的意思是，我记得我的一个孩子在医院里无法平静下来，助产士走进来，用毯子把他们裹得非常非常紧，然后把一个安静下来的婴儿交还给我。我当时觉得好像刚刚发生了奇迹。但是包裹襁褓对于安抚婴儿非常有效。所以事情就是这么简单。答案基本上就是它管用。它管用。这就是简单的答案，但它背后也有理论支持，所以助产士
would write jane sharp would write for example that um swaddling children is essential for their limbs to grow straight and that's what you want is strong straight limbs so if you swaddle them tight you know you lay them out nicely and swaddle them tightly then that would encourage their limbs to you know to settle into a straight formation and then um it was there was timetables for unswaddling so at about four months you might then release the infant's arms and then move on so so it talks a lot about midwives i have a question about fathers right what are they doing are they helping or are they loitering outside looking at their phone talking about the football having a cigarette. Yeah, yeah.
简·夏普（Jane Sharp）会写道，例如，给儿童裹襁褓对于他们四肢长直是至关重要的，而这正是你想要的——强壮笔直的四肢。所以如果你把他们裹得紧紧的，你知道，把他们舒舒服服地放好并紧紧裹住，那么这就会促使他们的四肢稳定成笔直的形状，然后，包裹襁褓是有时间表的，所以在大约四个月大时，你可能会释放婴儿的手臂，然后继续进行……所以这谈到了很多关于助产士的内容。我有一个关于父亲的问题，对吧？他们在做什么？他们在帮忙吗？还是在外面闲逛，看着手机，谈论足球，抽烟？对，对。
Yeah. So are there some who get involved? Or are they never welcome? They're not really welcome. I mean, you do get odd examples of a father being there because something's happening and they need to get involved. But also, you know, if you're thinking about people who live in quite close confinements, then people were trying to get on with their lives
对。那么有没有一些人参与进来呢？还是他们从来都不受欢迎？他们其实并不受欢迎。我的意思是，你偶尔会看到父亲在那里的例子，因为有什么事情正在发生，他们需要参与进来。但同时，如果你考虑到那些住在相当狭小空间里的人，那么人们正试图继续他们的生活
around these continual births every couple of years um so yeah it wasn't that they were completely absent they weren't welcome in the birth chamber it's go and find something to do we'll let you know well actually dominic that sets up this question perfectly it's another question from sadie and i very much get the impression that she's asking on behalf of a midwife because she says that this is apparently a common myth among midwives is it true that Louis the 14th had a fetish for watching women give birth and that this led to the practice of women giving birth on their backs well I wouldn't like to um comment on what louis the 14th's fetishes were but um he certainly is on record as having watched deliveries and insisted on being present um and again i mean in a way
围绕着这些每隔几年就会持续发生的分娩。所以，是的，并不是说他们完全不在场，而是他们在产房里不受欢迎，他们会被告知：“去找点事做吧，我们会通知你的。”实际上，多米尼克，这就完美地引出了这个问题。这是来自萨迪（Sadie）的另一个问题，我强烈地感觉到她是代表一位助产士在问，因为她说这显然是助产士中间的一个常见神话：路易十四对看着女人分娩有恋物癖，这是否属实，并且这是否导致了女性仰面分娩的做法？嗯，我不太想对路易十四的恋物癖发表评论，但可以肯定的是，有记录显示他观看了分娩并坚持在场。而且，再次强调，某种程度上，
royal births are very different from everyday births so there would be a chamber full of people i mean um royal women have the sort of ordeal of giving birth in a sort of public way, don't they? And the royal physician would be at hand. Because otherwise bedpans and all that malarkey. But the story goes, doesn't it, that Louis XIV wanted to be there at all the births, including his mistresses and things like that. And he was just fascinated by the process. But it wasn't him really who had any influence over what the wider population were doing. But one of his contemporaries, so a Parisian physician,
皇室分娩与日常分娩非常不同，所以房间里会挤满人。我的意思是，皇室女性必须以某种公开的方式经历分娩的煎熬，不是吗？而且御医会在一旁待命。否则就要处理便盆和诸如此类的乱七八糟的事情。但故事是这样的，不是吗？路易十四希望出现在所有分娩现场，包括他的情妇等等。他只是对这个过程着迷。但这并不是他真正对更广泛人群的做法产生任何影响。不过，他的同代人之一，一位巴黎内科医生，
Francis Mauricio, who wrote a book in French in 1668 on childbirth, and it was later translated into English. And in his book, he talks about women getting onto the bed when they're due to go into the final stages and start pushing. All people at this time believe that the best thing, what we would now call an active labour, that women are encouraged to go for. To squat. To walk about, squat, yeah, absolutely, birthing balls.
弗朗索瓦·莫里斯索（Francis Mauricio），在1668年用法语写了一本关于分娩的书，后来被翻译成英语。在他的书中，他谈到女性在临近最后阶段并开始用力时爬上床。当时的所有人都认为最好的事情——也就是我们现在所说的主动分娩——是应该鼓励女性去做的。下蹲。四处走动，下蹲，是的，绝对的，分娩球。
Because they used to have birthing chairs, didn't they? Yeah, absolutely. And there's examples of that going back to antiquity of birthing stones being these sort of passed along um you know the family and birthing chairs was part of a midwife's kit would be um to have some sort of a stool like they could be very simple affairs like a dairy dairy stool three-legged dairy stool um and the ones you see with with examples like that they've got no back and think well that can't be very comfortable but that's where your gossip's coming of course they're stood behind you they're being the back they're supporting the friend or the family member in labor and somebody else might be holding her arms and even if a woman did give birth on a bed at the
因为他们过去有分娩椅，对吧？是的，绝对有。有证据表明，早在古代就有分娩石，这些石头在家族中代代相传，而分娩椅是助产士工具包的一部分，会配有一种凳子，它们可以是像乳品凳那样非常简单的东西，三条腿的乳品凳。你看到的带有这种例子的凳子没有靠背，你会想“这一定很不舒服”，但这就是你的八卦朋友发挥作用的地方，当然了！她们站在你身后，充当靠背，支持着正在分娩的朋友或家庭成员，而其他人可能会抱着她的手臂。即使一个女性在床分娩
time that we're talking about in the late 17th century it would often be with with one of the gossip sat behind her, holding her. So it'd be semi-recumbent. So what we're talking about in Lewis' 14th time is a move towards a sort of semi-recumbent position. And what's driving that? Well, Mauricio is writing that that's the most optimal position for opening the pelvis. So he says that women should sort of become semi-recumbent and put their feet against something solid and and sort of bring their legs up open and that will that will give the best sort of way for the baby to be born and the best air the best way of the mother breathing so that's his that's his motivation for writing that but why he's had the reputation
在我们谈论的17世纪后期，通常会有某个八卦朋友坐在她身后抱着她。所以那是半躺着的姿势。所以我们在路易十四时代谈论的是向某种半躺姿势的转变。是什么推动了这一转变？嗯，莫里斯索写道，那是打开骨盆的最佳姿势。所以他说女性应该采取半躺姿势，把脚踩在坚固的东西上，然后把腿抬高张开，这将为婴儿的出生提供最佳方式，并为母亲提供最佳呼吸方式，所以这就是他写下这些的动机。但为什么他会有这样的声誉
for being the person who wrote this and was the first person and he is practicing at the same time as um lewis 14th was was in charge that passage um came from aristotle right right so um yeah so it's a long-held sort of view in some sort of circles but i think the reason you don't see it circulating more widely is because it's just not what people routinely did so women now lie down on their backs to give birth because of aristotle well they don't live they don't lie down on the backs now though no they did for a sort of period in the 20th century when it was it was the only way it was sort of allowed um so i've got a question actually from from a friend of mine called marina colville um and uh she and her husband are great fans of the show and she sent me a long email with her question
作为写下这一点并且是第一个这样做的人，而且他执政时路易十四正当权，那段话其实出自亚里士多德，对吧？所以，是的，这在某些圈子里是一种长期持有的观点，但我认为你没有看到它更广泛流传的原因是，这根本不是人们惯常做的。所以女性现在为了生孩子而躺在背上是因为亚里士多德？嗯，她们现在不躺在背上——不，她们在20世纪的一段时间里确实那样做过，当时那是唯一被允许的方式。所以，实际上我有一个问题来自我的一个名叫玛丽娜·科尔维尔（Marina Colville）的朋友，她和她的丈夫是这个节目的超级粉丝，她发给我一封长邮件，里面带着她的问题，
which is about the medicalization of childbirth and she says you know has has it does a lot of historical research concentrate on it as a kind of medical event rather than as where a natural event and have we moved on as a society? Or why haven't we moved on, sort of taking it out of the realm of the medical where you needed to the doctor on hand and seeing it as more natural? Where do you think the sort of the focus is at the moment? Do people still see it as medical? Or do they see it as more part of, as it were, the natural processes of life? I think that there was a time when, because the medical textbooks were the most easily accessible source that we had to hand, that there was a tendency to go down that
关于分娩的医疗化，她说，很多历史研究是否倾向于把它集中视为一种医疗事件，而不是一种自然事件？我们作为一个社会是否已经前进了？或者为什么我们没有前进，把它从你需要医生在场的医疗领域中抽离出来，并把它视为更自然的事情？你认为目前的焦点在哪里？人们仍然把它视为医疗行为吗？还是把它视为生命自然过程的一部分？我认为曾经有一段时间，因为医学教科书是我们手头最容易获得的资源，所以人们倾向于沿着那条路线走下去
route and look at what these textbooks were saying and to take that as if that was necessarily what happened in all cases. And then there was also the structural changes in society. So you start with the lying in hospitals in london from the mid 18th century and a process that takes actually hundreds of years to get to get women into hospitals but there are now a lot of people who are focused primarily and i think probably um you know going back to what i said about you know the work in the 80s of people like dayla fitharley we were looking at midwifery there was always um a sort of acknowledgement about what women's experience was what women's lived experience was and there's a brand new book that only just came out last month giving birth in the 18th century um which
去看看这些教科书在说什么，并把它当作所有情况下必然发生的事情。然后社会也发生了结构性变化。所以从18世纪中期伦敦的产科医院开始，一个实际上花了数百年时间才让女性进入医院的过程开始了。但现在有很多人主要关注——而且我认为可能，你知道，正如我之前所说的关于80年代戴拉·菲·哈利（Dayla Fitharley）等人的工作，我们在研究助产术——一直有一种对女性经历、女性生活经历的某种承认。并且有一本刚刚在上个月出版的全新书《在18世纪分娩》，它
is very much interested in women's experience and what it was like to be part of a community and what happened and that um is yeah is investigating what it was actually like and the title's brilliant because it just is about giving birth in the 18th century um so yeah so yeah we've sort of addressing that in print a lot now and she asks a follow-up question which is why haven't all the research that's been done on the experiences of women and the lives of women and the sort of primacy of women's own experience of childbirth rather than that of the doctors and of the kind of medical profession why hasn't that improved maternity services the question is i guess why is it still sort of quite top down and quite sort of focused on the doctor rather than on the the
非常关注女性的经历、作为社区一部分的感受以及发生的事情，这确实在调查实际情况是什么样的。这本书的书名很棒，因为它就是关于在18世纪分娩的。所以，是的，我们现在在出版物中对此进行了很多探讨。她提出了一个后续问题：为什么所有关于女性经历、女性生活以及女性自身分娩经历的主导地位的研究——而不是医生和医疗行业的经历——为什么这些研究没有改善产科服务？我想问题在于，为什么它仍然带有居高临下的色彩，并且相当侧重于医生而不是
the mother or is that actually not a fair um description of it i think yeah i mean i think it can feel like that i think when you get into the system you can very much feel like it's top down and that women struggle to get their voices heard. I don't know that that's, you know, that's the universal experience. There's a great new program, isn't there? The Yorkshire Midwives, it's just started now. And it's about community midwives in Yorkshire and how they're facilitating home births. And it's a wonderful reality show. I think it's only had a couple of episodes aired, which shows what's going on in Bradford to listen to women and to facilitate wherever possible them giving birth at home, those who would like to. Well, so could I ask now about Call the Midwife?
母亲？还是说这其实并不是对它的公平描述？我想，是的，我的意思是这确实会有这种感觉。我想当你进入这个体制时，你确实会强烈地感觉到它是自上而下的，女性很难发出自己的声音。我不确定这是否是普遍经历。有一个很棒的新节目，不是吗？《约克郡助产士》，刚刚开播。它讲述了约克郡的社区助产士以及她们如何促进顺产。这是一个精彩的真人秀。我想它才刚播出几集，展示了布拉德福德正在发生的事情：倾听女性的声音，并在可能的情况下尽可能帮助那些愿意在家分娩的女性在家分娩。那么，我现在可以问问《呼叫助产士》吗？
He's been dying to do this. Well, I think it's a fabulous piece of historical drama because it takes you up close to look at how cultural assumptions evolve and change. But also it's about the infrastructure of how midwifery services are provided, isn't it? And how women come to give birth, because what you're seeing is simultaneously the improvements that a national health service bring to people in the East End who previously, I assume, are often at great risk. But at the same time, it's a group midwifery practice centered in a nunata's house, a kind of religious community of nuns.
他一直渴望这样做。嗯，我认为这是一部极好的历史剧，因为它让你近距离观察文化假设是如何演变和改变的。但这也是关于助产服务如何提供的基础设施，不是吗？以及女性如何分娩，因为你看到的是国民健康服务（NHS）为东区的人们带来的改善，而这些人以前我猜往往处于巨大风险之中。但与此同时，它也是一个以修女院为中心的群居助产实践，一种修女的宗教社区。
The difficulty of ultimately of integrating that kind of approach with a more kind of top down nationalized approach. And do you think that, I mean, what is your impression as a historian of childbirth and midwifery? What do you make of Call the Midwife? I draw Call the Midwife. The early episodes episodes the early series which are pre-nhs you can see how important that service that was offered by the nuns was um to assisting the women of poplar who were amongst the poorest in the country living in overcloud overcrowded in sanitary conditions and they are based on the memoirs of jennifer worth
最终将这种方法与更具自上而下的国家化方法相整合的困难。你觉得，作为一名分娩和助产史学家，你的印象是什么？你对《呼叫助产士》作何评价？我提取了《呼叫助产士》的元素。早期的剧集——早期的系列节目是在NHS成立之前的——你可以看到修女们提供的服务是多么重要，用于协助波普尔（Poplar）的女性，她们是全国最贫困的人群之一，生活在过度拥挤、卫生条件极差的环境中，而这些是基于詹妮弗·沃思（Jennifer Worth）的回忆录，
who was herself one of the nuns. She wasn't a nun. She was one of the midwives who worked in that sort of an environment. And so they are based on firsthand memoirs. And so, I mean, the later episodes, obviously, they're imagining a continuity. Because they're going into the 60s, aren't they? But, you know, people sort of think of it as being sort of a little bit saccharine. But it's the opposite of that, I think, as a historian. You know, they deal with flamidamide and things like that.
她本人就是那些修女之一。她不是修女。她是曾在那种环境下工作的助产士之一。因此它们是基于第一手回忆录的。所以，我的意思是，后来的剧集显然是在想象一种延续性。因为她们进入了60年代，对吧？但是，人们有时会认为它有点过于甜腻。但作为一名历史学家，我认为它恰恰相反。你知道，他们处理了反应停（Thalidomide）之类的事情。
You know, tackling that sort of prime time viewing is very brave and very important, I think. And so, yeah, I think we know that the birth scenes on Call the Midwife are authentic because the clinical editor, Terry Coates, is involved in every aspect. So she oversees every single birth presentation. She's there working alongside the production throughout. She looks after the babies because the babies, you know, are taken from really newborn babies that are starring roles.
你知道，在黄金时段处理这种题材是非常勇敢且非常重要的，我认为。所以，是的，我想我们知道《呼叫助产士》中的分娩场景是真实的，因为临床编辑特里·科茨（Terry Coates）参与了各个方面。因此她监督每一个分娩呈现。她全程与制作团队并肩工作。她照顾婴儿，因为这些婴儿真的是由刚出生的婴儿扮演主角的。
Terry oversees the way that this happens to make sure that it is authentic and realistic. I'm sure I wouldn't have watched it had Zadie not made me watch it. I was gripped absolutely from the beginning. And I think the reason why it's completely gripping, it's not just the kind of Dickensian blend of, you know, make him laugh and make him cry, which it does very effectively on both levels. I can't think of a drama series that has shown the process of social change in Britain quite so brilliantly. And it brings home to you how central midwifery and childbirth is to a culture, the way that it is understood and the way that kind of approaches to it evolve yeah absolutely it does so you get the the very early parts of it when there was no concept of um an nhs and women who couldn't afford to get help generally would would be managed sort of in social groups wouldn't it's basically with with going back to the hand woman
特里监督这一切的发生方式，以确保其真实逼真。如果不是萨迪逼着我看，我肯定不会看。从一开始我就被深深吸引了。我认为它完全引人入胜的原因，不仅仅在于那种狄更斯式的融合——让你笑也让你哭，它在两个层面上都非常有效地做到了这一点。我想不出有哪部剧集能如此精彩地展现英国社会变革的过程。它让你深刻认识到助产和分娩对一种文化的核心意义，它被理解的方式以及与之相关的态度是如何演变的。是的，确实如此。所以你会看到它非常早期的部分，当时还没有NHS的概念，那些负担不起医疗费用的女性通常会在社交群体中得到照顾，也就是回到接生婆那里，
um and you see the regular um the way that the nhs comes in and intervenes and like you say that then that's got to be negotiated hasn't it Because now we've got this sort of monolithic organisation saying this is what's going to happen. And it tackles all that head on. And it shows that the tensions that exist around the foundation of this new way of doing things. So we've got one last question, I think, Tom, which I think is the question that everybody's been looking forward to.
嗯，你会看到常规的——NHS介入的方式，就像你说的，这就必须进行协商了。因为现在我们有了这个庞大的组织说“这就是将要发生的事情”。它正面应对了这一切。它展现了围绕这种新做事方式的建立而存在的紧张关系。我想我们还有一个最后的问题，汤姆，我认为这也是每个人都期待的问题。
So it's from Anthony Buck. This is probably a slightly harsh question to ask you sarah but i think everyone wants to know the answer which of the two presenters of the rest is history do you think would be the most effective birthing partner well i think i i think that's a very unfair question to spray on sarah who's only met us for under an hour. I think first impressions are often very revealing, Tom. I think it would be Tom, actually. I've seen more episodes of Call the Midwife.
这个问题来自安东尼·巴克（Anthony Buck）。这对于莎拉来说可能是一个有点苛刻的问题，但我认为每个人都想知道答案：《历史的其余部分》的两位主持人中，你认为谁会是最称职的分娩伴侣？嗯，我觉得这是一个非常不公平的问题，抛给只和我们见面不到一个小时的莎拉。我认为第一印象往往非常有启发性，汤姆。我想实际上会是汤姆。我看过更多集的《呼叫助产士》。
Right, because all those hours spent watching Call the Midwife can't, you know, they've got to count for something. It's all about the hot water. Hot water and towels, Dominic. That's what it's all about. That's what I would have assumed.
对，因为所有花在看《呼叫助产士》上的时间，它们总得算数吧。这一切都关乎热水。热水和毛巾，多米尼克。这就是全部。这就是我所设想的。
I'd do the prayer at first, I think. I'd kick off with the prayer. It worked in the 17th century. Actually, I've got one last question, and it's a very broad one. As a historian of childbirth, which is such a primal experience, what's more significant, the commonality of the experience or the differences that have affected how women give birth over the course of the centuries and across the
我想我会先进行祈祷。我会以祈祷开场。这在17世纪很管用。事实上，我还有一个最后的问题，这是一个非常广泛的问题。作为分娩史学家——这是一种如此原始的体验——什么更重要：经历的共同点，还是跨越几个世纪和全球影响女性分娩方式的差异？
sweep of the globe? I think it comes back to the commonalities for me. It is a physical process that, you know, is essentially the same over the years. The way that it's culturally determined through how you give, you know, the environment in which you give birth, so whether you're in a very sterile medicalised environment, whether you're at home with support, or whether you're in a very sterile medicalized environment whether you're at home with support or whether you're just surrounded by a group of friends and doing it as as your body's dictating essentially the process the physical process of giving birth is the same throughout time and reading women's letters and diaries from the 17th century as I do they don't talk very much about the physical experience of giving birth, but they do talk about the processes as their family grows. And they do talk about the feelings towards
对，我认为这对我来说回到了共同点。这是一个物理过程，你知道，多年来基本上是一样的。它通过你如何分娩来进行文化决定，也就是说你分娩的环境——无论你是在一个非常无菌的医疗环境中，无论你是在有支持的家中，还是在一个非常无菌的医疗环境中，无论你是在有支持的家中，还是你只是被一群朋友包围着，按照你的身体本质上的指令去做——分娩的物理过程在整个时代都是一样的。阅读17世纪女性的书信和日记就像我所做的那样，她们其实并没有太多谈论分娩的身体体验，但她们确实随着家庭的增长谈论了这些过程。她们确实谈论了对即将到来的分娩的感受
the impending labour. And they do talk about the physical recovery afterwards and things like that. And you get a sense, you know, that you're reading the accounts of women who've been through this much the same as I did. It connects you in a way with women who lived hundreds of years ago. Brilliant. Well, as you have connected us to them, thanks so much for coming on. I hope everyone's enjoyed this and we will be back again with more in due course. Thanks ever so much. Bye-bye. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
并且她们会谈论之后的身体恢复之类的事情。你会有一种感觉，你知道，你正在阅读经历过这一切的女性的陈述，这和我的经历非常相似。它以某种方式将你与几百年前生活的女性联系起来。太棒了。好吧，既然你把我们和她们联系在了一起，非常感谢你能来。希望大家都能喜欢这次访谈，我们适时还会带着更多内容回归。非常感谢。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. That's restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有关独家剧集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。网址是 restishistorypod.com 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。